[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID MUNRO: So just
to introduce ourselves,
my name's David.
I'm actually a product
manager at Google.
I work primarily on Service
Management and Istio, Istio
obviously being an
open-source service mesh
project that was originally
sponsored by Google and IBM.
But now there are a large
number of contributors
from a various--
a number of companies.
And also joining me
today is Sandeep.
Sandeep works in dev
role, also focusing
on Istio Service Management.
He's the guru around
all things technical
when it comes to Istio.
So when you have any
really gnarly questions,
please feel free to save them
for him when he gets up here.
So just let's cover what we're
going to talk about here today.
We're going to basically
touch on managing
services with a service mesh.
There are some--
service mesh actually
gives you a bunch of
different capabilities.
We'll also talk a little
bit about incorporating
some of the SRE best
practices into that process
and actually what
that looks like.
And we'll go through--
we'll actually
have a demonstration on how
you'd step through setting up
some practical examples of SLOs,
or Service-Level Objectives.
So this is what we're
going to focus on today.
But before we get started--
and again, it's a little bit
difficult for me to see--
how many people in
this room have actually
used Istio before?
Awesome.
I saw about-- it's hard to--
I can see some hands over
on the right-hand side.
I couldn't see any
on the left-hand side
actually, to be
honest, not because you
didn't put your hands up,
because the lights are
in my eyes.
How many people actually
have Istio in production?
OK, awesome.
That's fantastic.
I would actually love to--
maybe afterwards
we could catch up.
I'd love to understand what
you guys are doing with Istio.
So let's talk a
little bit about--
let's kick things
off with, what's
service management like in
a microservice environment?
So microservices
are pretty awesome.
The main objective
about microservices
is to fundamentally
increase developer velocity
and productivity.
So this is the key thing.
What we hear all the
time consistently is,
I want a common
development pipeline that
works for all my environments.
But I also want to be able
to get new capabilities
into the hands of my
customers as soon as possible
and do that very, very safely,
and really reduce risk.
So there are a
bunch of things here
that microservices allow you
to do that makes things better.
The challenge with
microservices,
though, is they
increase complexity.
So with that
increased complexity,
you start getting
some additional things
you need to do in order to
manage those microservices.
So things like orchestration
becomes important.
Understanding how your
services get connected
becomes important.
So you actually need a
high level of abstraction.
This is where, again, Kubernetes
gets you partway there,
but Istio or service
mesh can actually help.
That provides at a high
level of abstraction.
So let's look at a--
so I actually have a really
pretty basic application here.
This is a demo app.
And if I had a software
developer first
join a development
team, and we're
looking at building
an application
or we had an application
already in production,
I'd probably-- people
would get on a whiteboard,
and I'd start drawing stuff out.
And you'd end up with
a slimmed-down version
of something like this
that talks about what
that application looks like.
And even in this very,
very simple example,
we have around 10
microservices, which
you may be running
many instances
of from a back-end perspective.
And here, we
actually have a bunch
written in Go, some written
in Python, one in Java.
This actually gives
you the ability
now to deploy certain services
independently of [? other. ?]
I can scale, for
example, my front
end independently to
scaling my CheckoutService.
I can patch or release
AdService independently
of other services.
But I've also done
another thing.
I've actually created
complexity around managing
all these services, and also
managing the communication
paths between these services.
So we'll look at--
if I look at the
services themselves
and actually managing
those, I have
to now secure the
communications between them.
I have to protect the services,
put rate limits in place.
I don't necessarily want a
service hitting another service
beyond its load capacity, so I
can put rate limits in place.
I also need to
monitor the health
of the actual microservices and
understand the dependencies.
One of the things
that you'll hear--
putting SLOs, or
service-level objectives,
on a specific service
is very helpful.
And it gives you
some guideline--
and we'll talk about this--
around what's a best
practice on doing that.
But also, understanding
your service dependencies
and understanding
what the critical user
journey is across your
environment becomes important.
You'll actually
hear people start
talking about an SLO on the
critical customer journey
through my environment.
And I'll give you a
very specific example.
If you're just looking
at this for a second,
if front end goes down, I
actually have an outage.
That's a big deal.
If AdService goes down,
or RecommendationService
goes down, those things--
do I wake up a person
on call for that?
Maybe not.
So actually, really
understanding
the dependency map
within your microservices
becomes very important to
understand which ones really
impact your
customer-critical journeys.
So service mesh
is really about--
service mesh or
Istio really empowers
developers and operators
to focus on their business
and modernize and secure
their communications.
So this effectively
puts a lot of the toil
in looking after
the interconnect
between microservices
and securing them
into the infrastructure.
So your service
developers don't have
to worry about instrumenting
specific things
within their code.
They don't have to worry
about creating retries.
about doing circuit-breaking.
This actually becomes part of
the [INAUDIBLE] infrastructure
itself.
You want to secure
those services,
you can start enabling things
like mTLS between your services
based on strong
service identity.
So this actually allows
you to take control and get
a really good
understanding of how
your services are connected.
One thing Google is
good at is, they operate
distributed systems at scale.
There has been a lot
of effort around--
there's been a book
published around SRE.
But also, just look at--
the key goal of an
SRE organization
is to basically scale
and scale the services
that you're running
within your environment,
but also make them
resilient, reliable,
and provide a very good
end-user experience.
So the question, how does
that map to your organization?
Let's talk a little bit about
the three key pillars for SRE.
The three key pillars
really map to SLIs, which
are Service-Level Indicators.
We have SLOs, service-level
objectives, and SLAs.
I'm going to talk a little
bit briefly about all three
of these and how
they're different
and also why they're important.
So that one of the key reasons--
so if you think of--
one of the things
that Istio provides,
or service mesh
provides, is they
provide consistent
flow logs and metrics
across your entire environment.
These give you what we would
consider to be golden signals.
These are things that you can
look at from an error rate
perspective for latency
across your environment.
These become the key metrics
that you use in order
to construct your SLOs on.
SLOs tend to be
targets that you would
map to business service-level
objectives for your team.
So I've given-- the development
team would basically
look at what the
objectives they want around
uptime, around latencies,
for a specific service.
And you tend to do that over
a rolling period of time.
And we'll talk also a little
bit about error budgets
as we move forward.
SLAs, though, is a
little bit different.
SLA tends to be more
a business agreement
that you map to your customer.
So let's compare and contrast
SLOs versus SLAs for a minute.
So an SLO, to me, it
might be something
that I want to run on a
rolling period of time
over a week or a month.
But for an SLA, I
actually want to map it
to a contractual obligation.
So for that-- might
be important here is--
if I have an agreement for
my customers that I'm having
a certain amount of
availability for a given month,
I want to make sure that I'm--
if my error budget is
getting low for that month,
maybe I don't roll
out a version of code.
Maybe I actually
hold back and wait.
So I'm actually using the
error budget for an SLO
to give me business
indicators as to whether
or not I want to take the
risk to roll out something
from a business perspective.
And I think this is where-- so
we've sort of talked a little
bit about SLOs and SLAs--
but I think this is actually
where service mesh can really
come in and help.
There is a lot of things that
you effectively get for free,
from an infrastructure
perspective, when
looking at a service mesh.
So let's touch base
on the service mesh.
So the way that we tend to
talk about a service mesh
is, it's effectively a way to
connect and secure services
from a network traffic
perspective automatically.
It gives you-- another key thing
with Istio or service mesh is,
it does it in a
language-independent way.
It doesn't matter what version--
whether I'm actually writing my
application in Node.js or Go.
This effectively
just becomes, again,
part of the infrastructure.
There are three main tenets
to Istio or service mesh.
The first main tenet is
around uniform observability.
The second main tenet is
around operational agility.
And we'll talk a little bit
about how that actually helps
and what you can do with that.
And the last tenet is really
around policy-based security.
So let's take a little bit of
a look around observability.
So one of the things
with a service mesh
is, you tend to
deploy a sidecar proxy
co-located with every service.
What that does is, it gives you
that nice consistent flow logs
and metrics across your
entire environment.
From that, I get a very
good understanding.
I get, effectively,
metrics out of the box.
I haven't had to instrument
anything within my application
logic.
I can basically just
now deploy that sidecar.
Wherever that sidecar is, I'm
getting those consistent flow
logs and metrics.
The other thing that
we can do is we--
based on the actual
traffic flows,
we can get an understanding
of the topology
of the environment.
This isn't something that
is a theoretical diagram.
This is now based on the
actual traffic that is flowing
through your environment.
This is important for
a couple of reasons.
One is because, in
some cases, it's
sometimes even unclear as
to exactly what services
are communicating
with other services.
This gives you a representation
of what's really happening.
And it gives you the
ability, potentially, even
to start locking down
your environment based
on those communication paths.
It's actually kind
of hard to see.
It's a little washed
out on that screen.
But there are lines
between all those circles.
The other key thing is we
can actually now construct
SLOs in a consistent way
across all the services
within that mesh.
And that's actually something
that Sandeep will actually
go through.
So let's talk a little bit
about how you get started.
So there are a bunch
of different ways
you can deploy Istio,
any way from just
going to the open source
repository using Helm Install.
It's actually relatively
simple to get started.
In doing so, in Kubernetes,
you would actually
get something that sort
of looks like this.
There's a bunch of
Istio components there,
Citadel's-- effectively
the CA components.
You've got Galley, which does
all the configuration, Pilot,
which pushes all
the information down
to the sidecars,
telemetry, and policy.
I don't see telemetry.
I'm probably covering it.
That is, effectively, how
you can do policy checks
or integrate into back ends
in a very flexible manner.
Another key thing that's
important in the context of GKE
is Istio's sidecar injector.
What that does is, this
allows you to turn on,
on a per-namespace basis if
you choose to do so, where you
want those sidecars injected.
So this is a very
easy way to get
that proxy deployed for
every single workload
in that environment.
So what does that
actually look like?
So if I've actually
then deployed
a given service
within a namespace
that has the label inject,
the sidecar, when you actually
drill down into the
container itself,
you not only get the
application that's running.
But you also get that sidecar
just automatically injected.
So it becomes very,
very simple to deploy.
By the way, all these
screenshots that I'm actually
showing-- the last couple
have actually been on GKE--
but the previous ones are
all on an alpha program
that we actually
have available, too.
So if anyone is interested
in trying this stuff out,
please come see me afterwards.
And we'd be more than happy
to have a conversation.
And once you've done
that, you can effectively
then start monitoring.
You're actually good to go.
So this is effectively what
service managing gets you
from a--
going through that process,
deploying your service mesh--
it gives you these consistent
things, again, very cleanly,
out of the box.
This diagram's a little bit
better because the actual lines
are showing up.
But I think this
is kind of like--
one of the key things that
we're really focusing on here
is really embedding
this capability
within the infrastructure itself
to make it easy for people
to adopt this and start
monitoring their services
at the service layer.
So at this point,
I'd actually like
to introduce Sandeep
to come up and--
SANDEEP PARIKH:
Thank you, David.
DAVID MUNRO: --talk about
setting up some best practices.
SANDEEP PARIKH: Awesome.
Oh, can we go back
to the slides?
Not quite right
for the demo yet.
Thank you.
So how do you take everything
David just talked about
with Istio and
service mesh and start
applying some of those
SRE's best practices
to your services?
So remember, what automation
does Istio give you out
of the box?
It, by default, gives you
this uniform observability,
telemetry of logs,
traces, metrics
for all of your containers where
that sidecar proxy's injected.
It also gives you this
operational agility component--
so things like managing
traffic, rate limiting,
doing circuit breakers,
injecting faults--
you can do all that with Istio.
And it gives you a
single point of entry
for implementing policy
and security across, again,
either your entire cluster
or your entire namespace.
And that could be five services.
It could be 500.
So it gives you a lot
of this automation
to really apply policy at
scale across a large number
of infrastructure.
But let's focus on
observability here.
How do you make practical
use of the observability
and telemetry that Istio
provides by default?
And how do you use
that in your own work?
So let's recap again
really quickly.
SLIs are the metrics that
you'll need to track.
SLOs are the targets
that you want to achieve.
For example, you may say,
for a given service--
if you remember that
complex diagram earlier--
you may say you want
the cart service
to have 99% availability
over the course of a week.
Or you may want the front
end to have 99% availability.
But maybe the AdService could
be 90%, or 95%, availability
for a given week.
So those are the kinds
of targets that you're
going to want to set.
The SLAs, then,
are finally the--
after you do enough
of this work,
what are the sorts of business
and end-user guarantees
can you make about
those services
that you've instrumented?
So the first part
of this process
is figuring out which
SLIs do you care about?
There's a whole bunch that
Istio provides out of the box.
Which ones are the ones
that are important to you?
And it's going to be different
on a service-by-service basis.
For some, latency may be
very critical for something
like the ad-serving.
Maybe for the front end,
latency is critical.
But maybe the front end
also needs availability.
Some others might just need
availability versus latency.
It's a little bit
of a trade-off.
But the ultimate
idea is you want
to decide and take a good look
at those services in depth
and figure out which
metrics are the ones that
are most important for
that particular service.
Again, thinking about
how that's going
to impact the
end-user experience
or your other internal
customer experience--
your internal customers may
be other teams, other services
that they're running,
other dependencies.
So that's where you want
to take into account
all of that information
to decide and determine
which SLIs are important.
And then again, back to
SLOs, which ones are, again,
the ones that are most
important for those workloads?
Which ones are the
ones that are going
to be very obviously
impacting anything downstream
or upstream from you?
So that's an important piece.
And then, finally, how
do you use all that?
How do you put
that all together?
Well, the challenge with SLAs
is that it's a little bit
subjective.
It's not a complete sort
of mathematical operation.
There's a little
bit of work there
you can use to figure out,
well, if I know my SLIs,
if I know the targets
I'm trying to achieve,
I can use that to figure
out what my error budget is.
I could say, well,
I can afford to have
60 minutes of downtime in a
given month or a given year.
So you know what
you're working with.
But from that
point forward, what
that final guarantee
you have to make
is still a little
bit subjective.
You have some data
to back it up.
But there's still a little
bit of determination
to make before you can
make that guarantee
or that promise to
internal/external customers.
So what are the SLIs
that you get out
of the box with service
mesh and with Istio?
So you get six main things.
And these things are
dependent a little bit
upon what type of service you
have, whether it's HTTP or TCP.
But regardless of
whether it's L4 or L7,
you get these metrics,
again, right out of the box.
So that includes things
like request count,
the duration of the request,
the size, the response
size as well, or TCP
bytes sent and received.
And by the way, there
are variations of these
for both inbound and outbound.
So you get to know this
from the perspective of,
whether it's a source
part of the workload
or a destination part
of that workload.
And you have some ability to
control which ones, again,
are most important to you.
The important part of this is
that your applications don't
have to emit these at all.
This is all done inside
that sidecar proxy.
So when you deploy your
service, and that Istio sidecar,
or that proxy, is injected
along with it, because it's
functioning at
the network layer,
it's automatically capturing
all this information
and then sending it to
those telemetry back ends.
And those telemetry back
ends are then pushing it down
to the downstream monitoring
services like Prometheus
and Grafana, like
Stackdriver, like Datadog.
And there's a whole
mix of others.
So now that we know a
little bit about the SLIs,
what does it mean to start
tracking health in depth?
That's specifically
around the SLOs.
So you have to make a
few decisions as you're
trying to create these targets.
The first is, what is the type?
What kind of SLI
am I worried about?
And we give you two
options right out
of the box inside of the
Service Management alpha,
which is around latency
or availability.
And then, on the SLO side, on
that specific compliance piece,
you have to decide, what are
the goals I'm trying to achieve?
90%, 95%, 99%?
That's your compliance goal.
And then you have to
assign a window of time
to that, or a period
of time, whether you
want it to be a calendar week,
or a rolling week-by-week
basis, or a day-by-day
basis, or even up to a year.
And then, finally,
you have the option
of setting up windowed SLI.
So that actually adds
a little bit of-- it's
an optional piece there.
But it adds a little
bit more specificity of,
I want to achieve a particular
metric compliance goal
in a smaller window of time.
And then it'll aggregate
those windows up
to see if you're
reaching your compliance.
The documentation does
a little bit better job
of explaining it, and with a few
examples, but the idea being,
you have different
ways of evaluating
how you want to track those SLIs
and how you want that to add up
to your final compliance goal.
So we look at a few
examples of this.
And these are somewhat
interchangeable.
So don't just go by the rows--
those only pieces there.
But for example, we
could set a latency SLO
where we want to hit 90% of
all requests, or all responses,
are within 100 milliseconds.
And we want that to be over
a rolling five-day period.
And we also want it to hit
99% of those in an hour.
So what that really means
is, for a given hour,
99% of the requests have to hit
that 100-millisecond milestone.
And then the
aggregate, that 90%,
kind of rolls up from there.
On the next line, we have
an availability example
where we want to hit, again, 99%
availability within a calendar
week.
And we don't need
to window that one.
So we have a little bit
of room to figure out,
what's the right
combination here?
But really, again,
when you get back
to that final piece
around SLAs, you
can't make those guarantees.
You can't make those
promises until you
adopt SRE as a regular, ongoing
practice in your organization.
So the first thing really
is, not just deciding
which SLIs are important, but
exploring them fully, making
sure you have a really
good understanding of how
those metrics are functioning,
what those outcomes look like,
what that output looks
like and using that
and deciding which ones
are the most important.
You can't really--
you effectively
could monitor everything.
But that might be missing
the forest for the trees.
You want to pick the ones that
are most important to you.
So you want to make
sure you have a really
thorough understanding,
after a lot of testing,
around those SLIs.
And then you want to
set realistic targets.
Go back to that
example earlier of,
not every service needs the
same level of availability
or maybe the same level
of latency guarantees.
You might have to
make trade-offs.
You might not have a
5,000-person team to work with
here.
So you might have
to decide and say,
which ones am I going to
guarantee are 99% available?
Which ones am I going
to guarantee that I have
100-millisecond latency at 90%?
And with enough exercise
of those first two--
understanding those metrics
in-depth and setting those
targets--
after you do enough
of that work,
then you can start to get to
the next part where you decide.
All right, here is my
error budget for the year.
Here's how I can
make that, again,
that final guarantee
to my end user
or to my internal customer.
So with service management
alpha, what we tried to do here
is not just surface
all the data.
I think that's the
first easy part, right?
Giving you all that data an
easy-to-consume dashboard.
That's great.
We did that first
really important piece.
But the next part of it
is to give you the tooling
to go a level deeper.
And I don't mean
sort of one level.
I mean all the way through.
And our first foray here is
really around observability.
But as time goes
on, you could see
how that could evolve
to implementing
more around even just
some of the agility
or some of the policy and
security pieces as well.
But we wanted to start
with observability
because that's a really
critical amount of data.
And frankly, what we
hear from a lot of people
is, their first real reason
for getting into Istio,
getting into service
mesh, is because they
want that observability.
They want that level of detail
they can't get right now.
Or they want that
level of detail
that individual
teams have, but they
don't have it in a
uniform way across
their entire environment.
So from this dashboard,
the first thing you'll see
is some important pieces
across the top here--
services with alerts
firing, services
that are out of error budget.
And this is a
default deployment.
I just ran a couple of
things here as an example.
So it's not much
happening in this example,
but it's a starting point.
But then beneath that,
beneath that first level
of information, we show
you all the services
across clusters,
pods, namespaces
that are running right there.
And you have the ability to
filter down and dig into them.
And this table's
actually very active
where different lines
can be read or have
different little check
marks of showing you
which things are in danger
or running low on budget.
As you dig into an
individual service,
we'll show you a
timeline at the top.
And that timeline
actually shows you--
right now, it's blue because
there's no incidents.
But if there were
incidents or issues,
there are hard tick marks
there that you can dig into.
And you can narrow
that timeline and say,
well, I want to focus
on that one incident.
What happened during that time?
And then you have
the ability to go
through the individual
metrics or diagnostics.
The diagnostics include
things like logs.
You can look at
the infrastructure
specifically, like
which pods are actually
running the service.
And you could see some of the
inbound and outbound traffic
as well.
So you have the ability to dig
in here a little bit further.
And we surface a
lot of the data.
But we're trying to make it
easy, not only to see all of it
in action, but also take
action on it very quickly.
So I talked a little
bit about this.
What's interesting is
that everything you need
to see and investigate is here.
But in reality, once
you've spent enough time
understanding your SLIs,
setting realistic targets,
you really shouldn't
be spending a lot
of time digging into those
services again and again.
If anything, once you've
got really good SLOs,
you probably don't have to
spend a lot of time going back
through the metrics
again and again.
Because the important thing
that you need to know,
that you're out of error budget,
or that you're potentially
hitting outside of
your SLO boundaries,
that's going to be
surfaced up here as well.
So you'll see some of
that stuff automatically.
So you shouldn't
spend too much time,
once you've got
everything up and running,
having to reconfigure
things again and again.
So how do you-- again,
we talked, again--
we tried to take you from
what Istio provides you out
of the box, how you turn
that into SLO, SLIs,
and eventually SLAs?
Well, how do you do
this, again, in practice?
How do you get more and
more of that specificity?
So let's start with, again, that
reasonably complex workload.
This is the online
commerce app that we built.
And how do we
start to understand
what's going on there?
And let's pick a service
maybe that has some high tail
latency.
And first, we'll
examine all of them.
Then we'll pick something
that we want to drill into.
We'll dive deep into it
and create an SLO around it
after we evaluate
some of those metrics.
So if we could switch
to the demo machine--
all right, so here I've got the
service mesh/service management
Console up.
And can you guys see that OK?
Yeah?
All right.
If you can't, let me know.
Just stand up and wave.
Hopefully, I'll be
able to see you.
So the first thing
we've got up here,
we've got a bunch of
services deployed.
And you can see things
across the top like where
no alerts are firing, where we
maybe have alerts configured,
SLOs that are potentially
out of error budget, ones
that have no alerting
policies, or services
that have no SLO set.
So let's look at some of
those with no SLO set.
So we'll filter by those.
And now we can see--
and let's pick something here
that has a high tail latency.
I think CheckoutService
there has a high tail
latency at 99%, around
1,700 milliseconds.
And that's probably
not what we want.
We want checkout to be
a much faster operation.
So now we can dig into
that particular service.
All right.
Now we can see this through.
And we can also pull
down that timeline
if we want to take
a quick look at it.
And that time span can go
from an hour up to six weeks,
depending on how far
back you need to look.
But we'll leave it at an hour.
And before we get
to creating an SLO,
let's start taking a look
at some of the metrics
and some of the diagnostics
that we surface up for you.
Because right now, you'd be
in that investigative phase.
And you want to understand
what's happening.
So if we pull up the
metrics, we can see here--
and I'm going to hide
this timeline for now
so we can see more of it.
We break it down for you
by requests per second,
by the error rate, the latency,
and the request and response
sizes.
And if we focused a little
bit here on latency,
we can see that, generally
speaking, latency
is looking around, let's say,
200 milliseconds roughly,
about 99%.
That's 255 milliseconds.
But we do have some spikes here.
So we are seeing things like
2 seconds in some cases.
But we can change that
breakdown into, maybe,
by Request Operation.
So we can see which
particular methods are
driving some of that latency.
So for example,
the CheckoutService
has a single method
called PlaceOrder.
And so we could see that one.
And actually, I should mention
this CheckoutService is not
a HTTP service.
It's actually a gRPC service.
So this is servicing
gRPC calls just
like they were HTTP
methods, so it's
easy to browse through them.
So we can go through
here and take a look
around the latency piece.
If we look at the
Request Size, we
can also change
that breakdown again
by request operation
or request protocol.
We could even base it on
what is the source workload.
So in this case, all of
their incoming requests
for that service are driven
by the front end only.
So that's a little
bit of that one.
And then the last piece I wanted
to show you is the error rate
breakdown.
Again, because we
know the type here,
we know it's gRPC or
HTTP, we can actually
show you the HTTP
error code that's
coming back out the other way.
So in this case, we've had
zero errors, which is good.
We want to see a low error rate,
obviously, for our services.
Now, on the Diagnostics
tab, what we'll show you
there are error logs.
And we show you the
error log breakdown
by the types of
messages that you're
seeing in your error logs.
And these logs aren't really--
they're not really anything
in particular-- just
sort of default things
that we put in there
for this example.
The more interesting piece gets
into things like infrastructure
and connected services.
When you expose
the Infrastructure,
you have the ability
then to dig into--
all right, you
have a deployment.
You have a service.
Well, inside that deployment
are multiple pods.
Now we can see
each of those pods
and figure out which ones may
be driving some of those issues.
So we can see that
the high latencies are
coming from these two pods based
on these two rows in the table.
Then we could also take a look
at the inbound and outbound
traffic.
As we can see, all
the inbound traffic
is being driven by front end,
and all the outbound traffic
is going to other parts of--
so the CartService is
making outbound calls to--
or, I'm sorry, Checkout's
making outbound calls
to the shopping cart,
CurrencyService,
sending emails after you
place an order, maybe
the PaymentService.
And I don't want
to undersell this.
When we've worked with large
customer teams, where they've
had to take a large,
monolithic infrastructure
and turn into microservices,
they've done that exercise.
But what they
haven't realized is
how many dependencies they've
picked up along the way.
So when we were talking-- we
were helping a customer migrate
from a microservices deployment
on-prem to Kubernetes,
we actually had them stand
up team-by-team and tell us
what their dependencies were.
And as teams would stand up,
ones they didn't even expect
would actually
highlight and say,
actually, we're a
dependency on your service,
or you're a dependency
on our service.
And they didn't even
know about that.
So this ability to observe
those inbound and outbound
connectivity is fantastic
for a lot of teams
where they didn't
have this before,
because their microservice
teams are very large.
But now that we have some idea
of what those metrics look
like, let's actually go
back, and go back to Health.
And let's create an SLO.
So when we do that, we're
going to first pick a type.
As I mentioned earlier, the
two that we surface by default
are availability and latency.
So we'll pick Latency
because we know
that's a problem for
the CheckoutService.
And we'll pick a low one here.
Let's say we want a
100-millisecond latency.
We want that to be the
case 95% of the time.
And we want to set this to
be a Rolling 7-day Period.
And so when you pick all that,
if you look on the bottom here,
we'll actually
automatically name
those for you, which does
add a level of convenience,
if you want to glance
at these very quickly.
So 95% of all
requests need to be
less than
100-millisecond latency
in a rolling period
of seven days.
Now, if we want, we can actually
add the windowed version here
as well.
So we can add a Window Target.
So we want to say that,
within those time frames,
we want 90% of all
windows that are
5 minutes long to meet that.
And again, it updates that name.
So now we can say 90% of all
5-minute windows in a rolling 7
days meet 95% latency.
It's a little bit of
a mouthful, but it
does encapsulate exactly what
we're trying to track here.
I'm going to actually
take that one out.
And we'll go ahead
and create this SLO.
And you could see right
away, we've got some status.
We're actually out of error
budget already with that setup.
So the service level
indicator is telling us
that we're only hitting 5.9%
of that target instead of 95%.
We've actually burned, not
only partway through our error
budget, but all the way through.
We're actually negative by
about 5,000 minutes for the time
frame on our error budget.
And we're only at
5.9% compliance.
So this immediately
is a bad situation.
And from here, we
actually have the ability
to create Stackdriver
alerting policies.
So depending on
which SLOs, again,
are the most critical,
as part of your guarantee
or your promise to
the end user, you
may want to create
alerting policies.
Not every service being out
of error budget is equal.
But I think having that, again,
that notification to your teams
and saying, hey, we need to
address this immediately,
that's an important part
of this whole process.
So if I were to hit that, it
would open a new tab here.
And that creates a
tab in Stackdriver.
We're not going to wait
for that to load right now.
We'll come back to that one.
And then, why don't we do this?
While we're here, let's create
another SLO around availability
because that's another important
metric we're worried about.
So for Availability,
for the CheckoutService,
this is critical.
This is how we get paid.
So we want 99% compliance here.
And we want that to be
across a calendar month.
So for every month, we
want that to be the case.
So we need to hit
99% availability
in a calendar month.
And we'll create
that one as well.
Let me collapse this.
And you can see, actually,
this one got created above.
And we are currently
well within range.
We're actually currently
at 100% availability.
So we're above our target.
We've still got our
error budget remaining.
99% ultimately leaves
you with 244 minutes
where you could be down.
So we're still doing great
on that one for the year.
So that's good.
Now, if we go back to the main
Service Management dashboard,
we'll actually see this
highlighted here, specifically,
where the CheckoutService,
[? if ?] that's readable,
is out of error budget.
There's an SLO that's
out of error budget.
And we can actually
filter by those as well
up here at the top.
So we can see now
individual services
that are out of error budget.
So we could do the
same exercise here.
We can go explore the
ShoppingCartService
and, again, dig into this.
Now, this one actually is
great because we've actually
got some problems highlighted
in that timeline, right?
You see some red marks there.
So we could actually narrow
the window on this timeline.
And let's pick this
incident here earlier today,
and roll back-- this one.
And now we can actually see
what some of the problem is.
We can dig into the individual
metrics during that time frame.
Can see there was a sharp drop
here, relatively speaking,
in our requests per second?
Maybe we want to take a look at
what the request operation was
that drove that.
So getting the cart suddenly
got dramatically slower.
And again, we can
scroll through here.
We can see, at the same
time, we saw latency
go up somewhat dramatically.
It scaled quite a
bit up from there,
up to two seconds at the
99th percentile in one case.
So this gives you
this ability, again,
to zoom in and dig around
and, again, develop
that investigative
understanding of those services.
But really, you
probably wouldn't
be spending time doing this
once you've set those SLOs.
But in order to set good ones,
you have to be realistic.
You have to know the
metrics really, really well.
So it's all a process.
But it becomes-- as you make
it a regular practice as part
of deployment, you get better
at deciding when to do,
as David mentioned earlier,
when to do code pushes,
when you do deployments.
Well, if you're out of
error budget for the month,
you may want to hold off
and wait till the next month
when you've got a little bit
more room to move around.
And in that time
frame, maybe you
want to investigate
some of those metrics,
again, to figure out what's
driving this problem.
And one of the things we
mentioned, but we didn't show,
was tracing because that sidecar
works at the network level.
We automatically get traces
generated without instrumenting
your code at all.
So we didn't
instrument for logs.
We didn't instrument
for metrics.
And we don't even have to
instrument for tracing.
But we could actually
trace inbound requests
and outbound requests
and figure out
who's taking up the most
time in those requests
without anything,
without any extra work.
That's just something you
get right out of the box
with service mesh in Istio.
So that's a quick tour of
the Service Management UI.
Could we go back to
the slides, please?
All right.
So how do you get
started with all this?
Well, the first
thing is, if you're
really interested in digging
in, and testing out, and trying
this UI, trying this
new functionality that
takes that power of Istio
and opens it up and exposes
all that data and some of
those insights out of the box,
come find Dave and
I after the talk.
If we get kicked
out of the room,
we'll be out in the
hallway for a few minutes.
Come find us, and we can
talk to you about it.
If you want to learn even
more and dig in further
around some of those
Istio core capabilities,
I would definitely recommend--
check out this "Welcome
to the Service Mesh Era"
series that we wrote on
the Google Cloud Blog.
It goes through a bunch of
conceptual ideas around traffic
management, telemetry
with an SRE focus
around how to roll
security out using Istio.
And there are actually
companion tutorials on GitHub
that go along with it.
So you could actually try
those examples out today.
And then I would
definitely recommend
you learn about
Istio's telemetry,
and what it, again, it
provides out of the box
Because it does give
you quite a bit.
Now, what I will tell
you is, it gives you
quite a bit out of the box,
but you can always add more.
You have the ability to add
in your own custom metrics
that get captured by,
again, Prometheus, Grafana,
or Stackdriver, or
whatever the other services
that you might want to use.
I would also ask for your
help in shaping this user
experience.
If you're interested,
if you manage services
on a regular basis,
if you operate
these deployments,
or these platforms,
or these clusters
for your teams,
we want to hear from you.
We want to build the best
product we can to, again,
not just surface the data,
but give you the insights that
are critical to really doing
the best management job you can
of those services and
of that infrastructure.
So we definitely recommend,
if you're interested--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
--not sure where that
music's coming from.
Hope it's not me.
That was weird.
[LAUGHS] All right.
And then, what's next
for service mesh?
Well, this was the
first session where
we talked about service
management, service mesh.
And there's a whole host more.
And we recommend you
go to all of these.
I would even say, for some
of the 300-level ones,
if you're interested,
it's still a good idea
to learn that level of
depth and get into it.
There's actually one right
after this, in about 40 minutes,
around taking a deeper dive
through SLOs and error budgets.
And they talk about how
Stackdriver helps you
kind of, again,
surface up that data
and figure out how you
establish those error budgets,
and where you can draw those
lines around which SLIs are
important and how you make
those into SLOs and, eventually,
into SLAs.
And then tomorrow, we've got a
full day of a ton of sessions.
We've got some on
Thursday as well.
So by all means, please join
us, and bring your questions,
bring your stories.
We'd love to hear from you
before or after those talks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]